[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they'd have whatever you want please
everybody please for God's sake oh my
god
I've been receiving by the way my my
chair isn't I can't get it to stay the
right these tools are designed to make
you feel uncomfortable and insecure I've
been sitting on this tools my whole life
yeah all right let's start with you
Kumail because you made it all about you
eventually uh you've been to comic-con
many times what's your advice for
newbies at comic-con I would say you
know it's you gotta bring your a-game
you gotta have Purell I carry Purell
with me drink Purell shower and Purell
and also the other thing not many people
know everyone in a mask is a celebrity
so just go up to and be like whisper
like I know who you are and then get
them to sign your Ninja Turtle lunchbox
yeah now what about what else you
noticing about Comic Cons you've been an
old hand at this what have you oh you
guys know what stink shoulder is this is
what stick shoulder is okay I was taught
so you know a lot of like attractive
women will dress up as characters and
then do it to be like can I get a
picture with you and what they'll do is
they'll put their arm around the lady
and their armpit is in the girls
shoulder and so their shoulder starts
stinking it's false pink shoulder so
these ladies you'll see them they'll be
like pure Elling they're so now okay
Olivia let's find out if this is true or
not you've been to comic-con before you
were dressed very nicely you had a lot
of dudes putting their arm around you
did you experience that yeah I I have
been a victim of sting shoulders
let me
now you have yeah it just looks like
somebody just you know on my shoulder
yeah that's a real Stig chill man yeah
the invisible man's been at it again
you